all right we want to take in our life to
burn in Switzerland where the president
of the Swiss Confederation is holding a
news conference after emergency talks to
rescue Switzerland's second largest bank
and it's just been announced that UBS
Switzerland's second Switzerland's First
Bank the biggest bank in Switzerland
will take over a credit Swiss which is
in trouble they've been meeting for some
time now since Wednesday in fact
initially Wednesday of last week the
Swiss National Bank offered a 54 billion
dollar Lifeline to Credit Suisse but
that failed to reassure the market a
bank which is deemed too big to fail
well now the Swiss government announcing
that UBS Switzerland's biggest bank will
take over Credit Suisse let's speak to
Francis Coppola about this she's a
commentator and Economist and is joining
us from Kent in the UK thank you so much
for for being with us what do you make
first of this announcement today by the
Swiss authorities that UBS will be
taking over Credit Suisse was this
expected
I think it was and indeed I think
something like this has been on the
cards for a few months now really since
credit suite's got into difficulties
last Autumn
um it's it's been suffering um outflows
of deposits for really quite some months
now and it was difficult to see how it
could be resolved in any way that didn't
involve some kind of takeover
explain to us why Credit Suisse got in
trouble in the first place why is
Switzerland's biggest bank second
biggest bank in fact being rescued today
what happened
hello
well I think really I mean credit
species problems go back are some years
it's got involved in all manner of deals
that it shouldn't have done you know
like Mozambique tuna bonds and it lost a
lot of money when Bill huang's articles
Empire collapsed and it also got itself
muddled up in green sill
um and so that not only cost it money
and it's got a lot of lawsuits coming
down the road which might cost even more
money but it helped to destroy
confidence in the bank let's think about
Swiss banking is that you know it's
above all about you know integrity and
security and trust and the moment you've
got things like this going on in
something associated with The Swiss bank
you're kind of destroying the brand
um so
um it was difficult to see how it could
continue on its current basis with its
Investment Bank with all these other
things attached to it it needed to to
find a solution it's interesting that
you talk about the brand there because
we have the Swiss government saying just
now that they can consider these
measures to be the most appropriate
solution to strengthening both Market
confidence in Credit Suisse and also the
Swiss Financial Center do you think this
rescue will work
yes I think it probably will if only
because the Swiss government has a great
deal invested in making sure that it
does work and because the buyer is UBS
which similarly has a lot riding on this
because if it doesn't work then UBS and
swiss back and the Swiss government you
know have a real problem with with you
know that what their financial system
kind of stands for so I think it will
work there's an open question now about
how they will handle the investment bank
which is arguably the source of all the
problems what are they going to do with
it are they going to try and spin it off
are they going to close it down what are
they going to do with it I don't think
that's resolved yet
yeah Francis also this is coming as the
health of the Global Financial system is
in doubt right now last week we saw uh
the failure of two American banks are we
likely to see a repeat of the 2008
financial crisis here
no I don't think we are I'm missing the
problem in America is to do with their
mid-sized Regional Banks it's largely
contained to America I know things
travel on Twitter these days so things
that ought to be contained to America
have a tendency to go Global but we
should remember that our banking system
generally is far safer and better
firewalled than it was in 2008 and also
that central banks actually are on the
ball on this one we're both in America
and in Europe we have seen uh regulated
step up really quite quickly to stop
um any kind of disorderly collapse or
contagion and this this merger is
happening over a weekend with the
intention of it being a done deal by
Monday morning so that we don't get
contagion into the wider Financial
system
thank you very much uh for talking to us
about this thank you for your time if
you're just joining us on Al Jazeera
again breaking news from Switzerland
this year Swiss authorities announcing
that the country's second largest bank
credit Swiss which was in trouble uh
will be
um
sorry will be rescued by UBS
Switzerland's largest bank toxic me had
been going on on for some days now about
the Takeover of Credit Suisse which has
been uh in trouble on Wednesday of last
week the Swiss National Bank offered a
54 billion dollar Lifeline to Credit
Suisse but that failed to reassure
markets and now the Swiss Authority is
announcing that UBS the largest bank in
Switzerland will take over Credit Suisse
we'll have more reaction and Analysis
throughout the evening here on Al
Jazeera 9